يوميا تقريبا نتابع الكثير من الاخبار عن
سقوط ضحايا جراء انفجار لغم ارضي في مكان
ما حول العالم الاغرب ان بعض هذه الالغام
قد يعود لعقود من الزمن
الخطوره تكمن في ان معظم هذه الالغام لا
تتاثر بالعوامل الطبيعيه بل تظل تتمتع
بقوتها التدميريه حتى بعد ان تم تطويرها
لتكون اكثر فكا وصعوبه في تفكيكها لمناقشه
التحديات ازاله الالغام وكذلك ابرز
المناطق التي تشكل فيها تهديدا وجوديا
معنى الخبير الدولي السيد مدير المشروعات
الخاصه في شركه سيف لين البريطانيه
والمختصه بازاله الالغام حول العالم اولا
مصر اهلا بك معنا في عسكري تيريا بدايه ما
هي اكثر المناطق التي بها خطوره كبيره
فيما يتعلق بوجود الالغام
مساء وشكرا لاستضافته هناك حاليا نحو 55
او 56 دوله تعد رسميا ملوثه بالالغام
البريه وتختلف كثافه انتشار الالغام بين
كل واحده من هذه الدول فالعراق وتركيا
ولبنان خاصه في الجنوب لديها كثافه عاليه
من الالغام على حدودها وهذه المناطق تسيطر
عليها بشكل كبير السلطات المسؤوله عن
الحدود اما دول مثل اليمن واذربيجان خاصه
اقليم مؤخرا واثيوبيا وكذلك اوكرانيا
فالالغام فيها تشكل خطرا على السكان
مصر كلارك فيما يتعلق بنوعيه الالغام
والمتفجرات التي تتعاملون معها خلال هذه
الايام هل تختلف عن النوعيه التي يعني تم
زراعتها في السابق والى اي مدى تشكل تحدي
كذلك في عمليه انتزعها
الالغام البريه يمكن ان تصنف بشكل عام على
نوعين المضاده للافراد والمضاده للدبابات
اي حسب الهدف المصممه من اجله ولسنوات
طويله كان هذان الصنفان هما الشائعين ولكن
السنوات الاخيره حدثت زياده فيما تسمى
المفخخات مثل تلك التي توضع على جانب
الطريق وتستخدم حاليا بشكل اكبر وفي
الماضي فان اغلب الالغام سواء كانت مضاده
للافراد او للدبابات كانت تصنع في مصانع
عسكريه تابعه للدوله وتصنع خصيصا لاستخدام
الجيش اما الان ومع ظهور جماعات مثل
الحوثيين وداعش فقد بداوا بصناعه الغامهم
البريه المضاده للافراد والدبابات بانفسهم
وهي تصنع بكميات كبيره الا ان جودتها
تتباين مما ادى بنا الى مواجهه الصعوبات
معها اذا هذه هي الانواع الشائعه على مدى
السنوات
مستر كلارك على مدى سنوات تطورت مساله
صناعه الالغام وكذلك عمليه زراعتها لكن
على الجانب الاخر الى اي مدى صاحب هذا
الامر تطور في التقنيات المستخدمه في
عمليه ازاله هذه الالغام
[موسيقى]
هذا السؤال مثير جدا للاهتمام لان الاداه
الاساسيه لاكتشاف الالغام البريه هي كاشف
المعادن وبخلاف المعتقد العام فانه لا
يوجد شيء اسمه كاشف الغام بل هناك فقط
اجهزه تكشف المعادن المصنوعه منها الالغام
وبالتالي فان اكتشاف الالغام يعتمد على
صناعه الالغام من المعادن وساربط ذلك
بسؤالك السابق حيث ان الالغام الحديثه
تصنع بكميات قليله جدا من المعادن واحيانا
من دون اي معادن ولذلك فمن الصعب جدا
اكتشافها باجهزه كشف المعادن فدرجه تطور
اجهزه كشف المعادن وقدرتها التكنولوجيه
تحسنت ولدينا اجهزه متطوره جدا الان كما
ان المزيج بين استخدام الالات مثل الالات
المدرعه الكبيره قد تطور كثيرا مع مرور
السنوات وكذلك استخدام الكلاب حيث تعتمد
بعض الدول على الكلاب القصه والمدربه لكشف
الالغام ولذلك فان الشيء الرئيسي الذي
تغير عبر السنوات هو اداره المهام
وتخطيطها ما وفر المزيد من الامان لمزيري
الالغام كما اصبحت اكثر شموليه ما زاد من
كفاءه هذه العمليات ليغدو بمقدورها التخلص
بالكامل من كل الالغام وهذا بالتاكيد يعني
تطور اساليب اداره الجوده وضبط الجوده فقد
تطورت اساليب تخطيط المهام بالتوازي مع
التطور التكنولوجي مستر كريس الكثير من
الشركات الان بات تتطور تقنيات سواء تعتمد
على الذكاء الاصطناعيه او حتى الروبوتس
فيما يتعلق بمساله اكتشاف الالغام او حتى
المساعده في نزعها هل تعتقد بان هذه
التقنيات تؤدي المطلوب منها بكفاءه
التكنولوجيا من وجهه نظري ليست جاهزه بعد
فهي قيد التطوير والتكنولوجيا في هذه
الايام تتطور بسرعه فائقه فنامل ان تكون
جاهزه في اسرع وقت ولكن الان علينا ان
ناخذ في الاعتبار اذا ما كان هناك جهاز
يستخدم الذكاء الاصطناعي او كاميرا او
جهاز استشعار واخبرك بان المكان الذي تقف
فيه امن وليست فيه الغام واذا ما مشيت
عشره خطوات الى الامام فستكون امنا اما في
الخطوه الحاديه عشره هناك لغم لاعتقد ان
احدا من العاملين على نزع الالغام سيثق
بها الى هذا الحد ولكننا نامل ان يتمكن
الذكاء الاصطناعي والمسيرات في المستقبل
القريب من مساعده برنامج ازاله الالغام
اما الان فلم نصل الى تلك المرحله من
ناحيه كونها تكنولوجيا عمليه
مستر كريس في اليمن تقومون في بالمشاركه
في مشروع لازاله الالغام من المناطق التي
انسحب منها الحوثيون اين وصلتم في هذا
المشروع وكذلك ما هي ابرز العوائق التي
تواجهونها على ارض الواقع
[موسيقى]
بالمشاركه في المشروع السعودي في اليمن
لمعالجه مشكله الالغام وفي السنوات الخمس
من عملياتنا تمكنا من تطهير 45 مليون متر
مربع من الاراضي المزروعه بالالغام وبلغ
عدد الالغام التي قمنا بازالتها 144
الفارا ولكي اوضح لك حجم هذه العمليه فقبل
بضعه اعوام عملت في برنامج مكثف جدا في
جنوب لبنان لازاله الالغام التي خلفها
الجيش الاسرائيلي بعد انسحابه منها وخلال
ثلاثه اعوام من العمليات هناك لم نقم
بازاله ما يصل الى 30,000 رغم وقد قمنا
بتطهير المنطقه ما عدا تلك المحاذيه
للحدود وهذا يوضح لك حج ونطاق عملياتنا في
اليمن ومن اكبر المشاكل التي نواجهها في
اليمن هي المناطق الشاسعه من الاراضي
وكثره الالغام مشكله اخرى كبيره نواجهها
هي تصنيع الحوثيين الالغام بانفسهم بشكل
اساسي ولهذا نجدها متباينه في الجوده ولا
توجد مقاربه موحده لازالتها وعلينا
التعامل مع كل لغم على حده ومع استمرار
عملياتنا بدا عمالنا بمواجهه التهديدات
حيث وضعت مفخخات في حقول الالغام لحمايه
الالغام من عمالنا ومؤخرا بدانا نواجه ما
يسمى بالالغام القافزه وهي الغام تزرع في
الارض وهي مربوطه باسلاك واذا ما سحب
السلك او اذا وقف عليه احد يقفز اللغم من
الارض الى مستوى الفخذ وينفجر لتتطائر منه
كميه كبيره من الشظائع بشكل افقي موازن
للارض هذه الالغام قاتله وخطيره جدا ولا
تستخدم بشكل واسع في العالم اليوم اخر مره
استخدم فيها هذا اللغم بشكل واسع كان في
حرب البلقان في البوسنه منتصف التسعينيات
وهذا امر جدي علينا التعامل معه اما اكبر
تحدي في اليمن فهو اننا نعمل في سياق حرب
مستمره وعلينا اتخاذ كافه الاجراءات
الوقائيه لحمايه عمالنا ولكن حقيقه ازاله
كل تلك الالغام من منطقه مساحتها 45 مليون
متر مربع هو انجاز كبير جدا واذا ما حل
السلام في اليمن عن قريب فهذه المنطقه
التي تبلغ مساحتها 45 مليون متر مربع لن
تكون بحاجه للتطهير وستسمح بعمليات اعاده
البناء وحريه الحركه فيها المشروع كبير
ولكن هنالك العديد من المشاكل التي علينا
التعامل معها هناك